republicans know that they didn't
suppress enough of the vote in 2020.
if they had suppressed enough of the
vote in november
trump would be president right now
instead of joe biden so republicans have
launched
a nationwide voter suppression effort
it's already underway with 253 different
bills
in 43 states many of these bills
premised on false claims
that donald trump actually won the 2020
election now you have to give them
credit
they see the problem and they're trying
to fix it the problem is
record voter turnout in november gave
the election to joe biden
as they see it too many people voted
so the solution is to prevent people
from voting now
all of these bills in some way
attempt to restrict voting and ballot
access
the brennan center for justice has a
great analysis on this
and the playbook includes strategies
we're familiar with make it more
difficult to register
to vote by banning voter registration
that's automatic
by shortening registration windows
that's one part of the playbook
purge voters from voter rolls so they
believe they're registered they show up
and they're not
you can do that by putting in place
looser and looser guidelines for when
people can be unregistered and removed
from voter rolls
third part make voter id requirements
stricter and stricter
which we know disproportionately impacts
poorer people now how do they do this
the way you do it it's almost evil
genius
in order to get the voter id is free as
they say
but in order to get the voter id you
require more and more documents
that you have to bring with you to be
given the voter id
and these are documents which poorer
people
are less likely to have people with more
housing instability
are less likely to have retained and
some of the documents you need to get
your free voter id
cost money to get okay and they're
documents that take time to get
when people can't afford to take time
off from work to deal with bureaucracy
so that's how you deal with this quote
problem of too many people voting
through voter id another approach is you
add elements of
voter intimidation to voting you
increase poll watchers that type of
thing
few examples georgia senate republicans
have introduced a bill
that would end no excuse absentee voting
entirely meaning
you can't just say i want to vote
absentee because i want to
they restrict the reasons that you can
give to vote absentee
georgia house republicans have their own
sweeping bill which would
reduce the early voting period again
just shorten the days the number of days
people can vote
montana republicans want to end same-day
voter registration
missouri republicans want a new voter id
requirement
new hampshire republicans want to ban
out of state college students
from voting in new hampshire and they
want to end
same-day registration iowa republicans
already approved a bill that would
shorten voting hours
on and on and on now at the same time
that there are bills
proposed to limit voting there are also
bills proposed mostly by democrats to
expand voting access and hopefully some
of those will pass
but republicans aren't even pretending
they haven't been pretending for a long
time
they openly want to win not by winning
the hearts and minds of people with
policies that voters will like
they want to win by making it hard to
vote disproportionately for people that
are statistically more
likely to vote for democrats at some
point
and i believe that that point is now the
only way to deal with this is to pass
national election reform and to pass it
in a way
that it overrides state limitations that
republicans want to impose
and to prevent the next president from
just undoing it
easier said than done but is there any
better time to do it than when democrats
control the white house
the senate and the house of
representatives for at least
the next two years the time to do it has
to be now
and we'll be talking more about what
that effort could look like
in the future find me on twitter at
dpakman let me know your thoughts on
this
massive dump of voter suppression bills
across the country from republicans